foreign
hey you guys if anybody's there I don't
know if anybody's there because I don't
see any chat yet but you know what I
mean so maybe I'm talking to nobody hi
nobody what are what are you up to today
but uh yeah so here we are and it's
Sunday and we're talking about a movie
oh I wanted to mention because I didn't
actually notice this until after we did
finish doing the Sidetrack show on
Friday night but we actually finally
broke 13
000 subscribers
so we got a lot of people in there about
Lebanon I only just noticed yeah they're
all they're all piloted so does Tawny
get nude in this flick uh briefly yes
you can't see a lot of it
um because I was reading about kind of
the some of the background like around
this movie and stuff and she really was
uncomfortable like filming the the
shower scene that's in this yeah she
goes running out of the shower the the
ghost was getting her yeah even though
she posed for Playboy and stuff like
that but I don't know if that was after
this or before this
because this I didn't even realize this
because I remember seeing this movie I
Didn't I don't think I saw it in the
theater maybe I did but I saw it like a
bunch of times on cable back in the 80s
and I could have sworn that this was
post White Snake videos but no this is
this was before the white snake videos
that made her like super famous that was
like because that was until 87 and this
came out in 86. yeah the draw of this
movie is Tony katine all right pretty
much if you guys don't know who that is
when we were kids coming up in the heavy
metal scene she was on album covers and
Rockstar's newer and yeah she needed a
few yeah she was on the she was on the
album cover of rat and she's on the
first rat album cover she was David
coverdale's ex-wife I believe but they
were made yeah they were married a
couple years yeah we can't married a
couple years who she was man was was
kind of interesting she was
she was this Jewish American chick like
what what they called a [__] a Jewish
American princess she from a real nice
um Jewish Family
and she kind of ran away to go run off
with rock stars uh but she wasn't a
girlfriend per se
she was a player in the old metal scene
out in L.A
I'd probably put her
put her at like not really not really a
manager but like an agent
she had connections if if she liked you
um she could get you hooked up and get
you signed on a [__]
on a record label uh she was good at
spotting Talent
if if she picked you you were gonna be
[__] famous you know you're probably
gonna get signed
but she was hot you know she was very
much 80s hot that's what they were
looking for back then she was today I'd
call I'd say they were a little too
skinny by today's standards uh kind of
tall and thin
but still even today I'd probably say
she's probably about a nine out of ten
um she was she was cute the thing about
well I looked up because I was kind of
curious because I kind of remember her
being generally around and uh you know I
remember seeing her in this movie and I
remember seeing her in the videos and
her being on album covers and stuff
um she actually didn't get started she
um actually got started as a TV actress
so I guess she was like on TV and then
she was at first okay yeah and then she
was in bachelor party with um Tom Hanks
like in 1984. okay so she actually
started doing that I didn't really see
and then like later on in the 2000s uh
she had a lot of drug abuse problems and
so she ended up being on like reality
shows like The Surreal Life and
Celebrity Rehab and all I didn't see him
and stuff I didn't see him either but
that's what I looked up I don't think
that's a good representation of who she
was though she wasn't she wasn't a drug
abuse chick that's just how it went
eventually
she was kind of a lot like me and
Jenny's friend Imani she was you know
whose Amani is the girl we know and
Jenny has worked with her and uh she
basically made a whole bunch of black
metal bands you know [__] she like a
talent scout
kind of like that
um but when you see this movie you'll
see that Tawny was
talented in her in her own right too you
know she was she was talented chick
but she was kind of like the uh
the 80s [__] cougar you know she's
much older than you think she is when
you look at her she looks young I think
even in this movie she's probably in her
mid to late 30s but she looks like she's
in her 20s she just died a couple years
ago like in 2021 but when she was in her
late 30s early 40s she was you know
cougaring her ass off on these looking
young metal
guys you know that's just who she was
she was cool real cool
um
I also heard you know I also heard that
you know if you crossed her she could
destroy your career too she
yeah you know [__] she had power she
had power you know
Social Power
Senor stick says Jenny where did you get
a Creepshow sweater it's not like
exactly a sweater it's just like a long
sleeve shirt I actually got it at FYE at
the mall yeah which is crazy they they
had a bunch of different ones I have a
bunch of different ones like from the
same company like I have a Creature from
the Black Lagoon one I have a Cthulhu
one I have a Halloween one I have a lot
of different ones uh and have we
reviewed the wax Works series we have
not uh but I would like to at some point
because I actually really uh do like
those movies this movie I like I said
it's weird because I was watching some
earlier and I knew that it had sequels
uh it actually has two sequels which as
far as I know don't really have anything
to do with this one because this one the
end of this one does kind of set it up
like ooh could be a sequel you know what
I mean
um I didn't think that I had seen the
second one but then when I was watching
another review of the three movies I saw
clips from the second one and I'm like
oh wait that looks kind of familiar
maybe I did see that although I
literally can't remember anything else
about it I've heard that it's kind of
like I don't want to say it's like a
remake at the first one but it's just
like a really really similar story the
third one they said goes off in like
crazy Direction some people like it some
people don't this kind of this movie I
kind of I feel like this has wildly
mixed reviews it was kind of like it was
really successful when it came out in
1986 I mean probably because it only
cost like a million dollars to make and
made like several times that back
but I mean it didn't get great critical
reviews but it kind of steadily got a
cult following like over the years but
even nowadays I kind of like oh it's all
the different horror channels I watch
they're about evenly divided like some
of the people really really like this
and it's like oh it's underrated nobody
talks about it anymore and then I saw a
couple are like yeah I really hate this
movie but um you know it's it's tonally
very very strange like especially for an
80s movie and I had forgotten about that
because I saw this movie
easily a dozen times back in the 80s
probably more and I might have seen it
in the theater the problem with it is
it's it's a slow starter it starts off
kind of boring and slow for yeah 15
minutes of it I think yeah there is a
lot of setup and it's long for a horror
movie it's like an hour and 45 minutes
but as as it goes on it gets better
um and then you start kind of
appreciating it what's different about
it is that it's it's a horror movie
but it's a lot like a haunting episode
it's about a paranormal investigation
really and it's got It's got some balls
uh when it comes to the script I mean
they'll they'll have a decent character
or a character that's very interesting
and then they'll kill that character off
they'll kill off a lead character
back in the 80s um
they're um so it's just kind of and and
then it kind of goes cerebral and emo
about relationships and then it also
gets kind of like it's weird it's not
your normal
80s horror films it's really not no it's
good though
um it's kind of like Exorcist
kind of like
uh Amityville Horror
and what else I don't know man there's
no way to describe it it's it's its own
thing yeah like I said I had forgotten I
mean like I said I saw it a bunch of
times back in the 80s and early 90s but
I hadn't seen it for probably 30 years
and so I was really interested to watch
it again because I remember really
liking it like back then it being like
you know one that stood out to me and I
had forgotten just what a strange I
don't know I don't want to like oversell
that but it is like kind of tonally odd
yeah it is
um you know what I mean it in the sense
that it's more character driven than
your average kind of like movie from
that era and of that's about this would
suggest it's definitely trying to be its
own franchise
yeah well it I guess it kind of
succeeded because there were three of
them there were three of them it's
trying to it's trying to put itself
apart
from the horror movies of the 80s the
and and it did
I didn't see this in the 80s when it
came out I probably would have liked it
um but no it's it's uh is it good yeah
yeah it is
yeah I still liked it it's good I mean
you have to see it it's different
because we're of the right
generation where this this was actually
intended for us you know it was intended
for Gen X
so I see I understand what they were
trying to do
I I would have liked it in 87 but I
didn't see it I would have liked it
though I had just forgotten how heavily
invested in the love triangle yeah of
course it's not like a you know it's not
like a romance race but it does go very
much into the characters and their
relationship with one another and that's
like a big part of the plot like yeah
they're Supernatural stuff and yeah
there's horror stuff like toward the end
but it really seems to focus and Kevin
Tenney like the guy that wrote and
directed it who fun fact a couple years
after this would do the classic Night of
the Demons with Linnea Quigley this was
actually the first movie that he'd done
he was I think still in film School
when he wrote this and um he actually
got the idea if you've seen the movie
there's like a scene toward the
beginning of the film might be this
first scene where you know Tawny is at a
party or she's having a party like at
their apartment and a bunch of people
are there and her friend slash
ex-boyfriend Brandon has brought a Ouija
board and he's just being very
self-important and mansplaining about it
and so they like start using it and
Kevin Tenney said that he got the idea
for the movie like when he was at a
party where that actual thing happened
you know what I mean like the way you
see in the movie they they like you know
we were communicating with somebody on
the Ouija board and then like um the
ghost got seemed like it got mad and
then somebody's tire popped outside you
know what I mean or somebody's Tire got
flat so it's like so apparently this
really happened in real life to him and
that's what gave him the idea somebody's
saying this looks like straight to DVD
movie
um no uh in this era
a lot of the movies that you would see
you know at the dollar theater you know
yeah that were horror movies which are
lower budget they just look like this
the difference with this one is that it
is trying to be taken a little bit more
seriously it's it's not going the Evil
Dead route
but it it is kind of budget wise like
that it's trying to be they're trying
it's trying to get you to take it
seriously kind of like it was
um uh uh The Exorcist
yeah it does take itself very seriously
and I think maybe that's why
because the subject matter of it is just
is Supernatural and then it also has
like weird comedic things in it like the
like the girl that plays the psychic
who's just this kind of crazy like
over-the-top sort of character she was
cute I like that girl yeah I did too
like but um she was in Roadhouse too
actually okay but um which I mean she's
been in loads of things but I remembered
her from Roadhouse she played Carrie I
think yeah
um and you know the friend of Jim the
guy that one of the main characters and
the thing and he's kind of like funny
you know what I mean like do you see
spaz written on this man anywhere so
it's like they have like little comedic
things that are kind of like over the
top but then like the rest of it is like
really really serious like it's trying
to take itself really seriously and to
some extent I don't know it's it seems a
little strange but I think it does work
one thing that's interesting about this
movie that I kind of realized again when
I was watching it is that the character
of Brandon who's actually played by
Stephen Nichols and if you've seen this
movie you will probably not be surprised
a soap opera actor he was on like days
of our lives in general hospital and
stuff
um because he comes across like very
soap opera e so when you see him at the
beginning he's the one that like
introduces the Ouija board concept and
like I said he's so like he's such a
well actually [__] and he's just
like very very condescending and he's
just very oh it's pronounced Ouija like
he's very much like that and I'm just
like oh my God I just want to punch this
dude right in the dick but like as the
movie goes on he actually you actually
start liking him which I didn't think
was possible because he's so
insufferable like at the beginning of
the movie but then like as the movie
goes on and the relationships between
him and Jim deepen and you're kind of
like oh maybe he's all right you know
what I mean like maybe I just got a bad
impression of him at the beginning
because one of the things that's kind of
central to the plot is that the two main
guys whose names are Jim and Brandon
um Jim is with Tawny now like you know
they're a boyfriend and girlfriend but
she dated Brandon before but Jim and
Brandon were friends from childhood and
I guess when Jim quote unquote stole
Tawny from Brandon then they had this
huge falling out and now they're just
every time they every time they're in
the same room together they just like
snipe at each other like little [__]
yeah so there's a lot of that going on
and then like toward the end like they
finally reconcile after you know Tawny
gets possessed by the demon from the
Ouija board and they have to kind of
like join forces to like save her you
know what I mean so so I kind of like
that it was that character Focus I can
see how because I was watching this one
review that were like they thought it
was just like really really boring
um and they were like older guys too so
it wasn't just like you know 20 year
olds or something like that but
um so I can kind of see that if you're
kind of expecting more of like a
just real over the top gory you know
special effects heavy stuff like that
like a lot of stuff in the 80s was this
is not really like that like you said
it's almost like a little more
cerebral I don't want to go like oh it's
elevated horror or anything like that
but it is trying to take itself really
seriously it's a low budget movie and it
is like trying to focus more on the
relationships between the characters
rather than like crazy Supernatural [__]
now I'm not saying that there's not
crazy Supernatural [__] in there there
is but it doesn't go too weird it's just
uh I don't know it's kind of like a
mixture of
Evil Dead
Exorcist and
um
[__] what's the one with the damn puzzle
box and the Hellraiser Hellraiser kind
of like that it's kind of that's how I
kind of put it because Hellraiser kind
of took itself seriously uh in those
days a lot of other horror movies were
kinda
cartoon you know it's like watching it
to have cartoon yeah wishing there's
nothing wrong with that but it's like
yeah they're fun we love it yeah we
loved it yeah
like uh [__] [__] reanimator the
whole reanimated series that was like
watching a cartoon yeah but it was great
you know because it was just instant
bang for your buck you know it's not
like that
that's in it that kind of stuff you know
you could tell that that's what kind of
movie it is but they're trying to be a
little bit more cerebral like an
expensive movie you know which okay
that's how they did it yeah yeah
and like I said because it was
successful like
this was really I mean uh you know Kevin
Tenney's first movie that he had ever
written and ever directed so I mean you
know it could have been a lot worse
that's for sure what surprised me is
that Tony could act
yes it's not bad now I will say that I
don't I think the acting in this is a
little like from oh it's pretty much
everybody yeah it's a little uh stilted
yeah it's a little you know what I mean
a little bit well a lot it has to do is
to edit it was just kind of [__]
edited together to be a certain way but
uh I think she shines in it though she's
one of the one of the better performers
in it the guys are okay uh like you said
it's a little uneven yes but
kind of like something up you know like
TV level actors you know well that's
yeah I think like I said the guy that
played Brandon was a soap opera actor
right yeah and it does kind of come off
a little bit like that still that's
pretty good because in a lot of people
moves from this era they weren't actors
at all it was just somebody's friends
that's true you know they had nice tits
or something yeah but uh at least
they're trying in this one sure and even
the psychic chick which I like that
character you know yeah I mean it's over
the top it's over the top for sure but
she was a fun character and they killed
her off rapidly
yeah you're like oh man I thought she
was gonna be like a main character in
this now yeah I mean she comes in with
like crazy like new wave hair and like
the glasses and she's constantly like
clattering because she has like a fringe
jacket like all this jewelry and stuff
like that and just the way she talks is
like [__] if you've seen it you know
what I'm talking about but it's like
it's just it's like it's borderline
annoying but also kind of entertaining
also you know what I mean because she is
a likable character and everyone else is
like being so serious that it's kind of
like a breath of fresh air like when she
comes in there yeah and like starts
being but I I don't know I I kind of
feel like how you feel about it is like
you know uh it I don't know it's just
like on the edge of Annoying It's just
on the edge of annoying you know what I
mean like she can get kind of annoying
what I don't think she was as annoying
to me as the cop character
cop character you know the one that was
like
um you know the first guy that dies in
the movie whose name is Lloyd who's like
a friend of gyms oh the cop guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah and like and uh Lloyd
gets killed when like some Sheetrock or
something like that like fought like
because him and Jim work on a
construction site and uh the sheetrock
falls on him the ghost actually kills
him like we know that but you know day
everybody else just thinks it's an
accident but for some reason this cop
does not think it's an accident because
like oh well the rope that was holding
up the sheetrock like was caught looked
like cut with a hatchet blah blah so he
seems to suspect that Jim like murdered
his best friend so he keeps popping up
and every single time he pops up he
talks about magic tricks that's kind of
his thing and just and I don't know I
think after a while it gets like a
little
yeah a little tedious and plus at one
point did you notice that at one point
he said when he was talking about hey
you know out in Vegas they have that
show that he says Sigmund and Roy yeah
and I said it's Siegfried it's Siegfried
and wrong right and I was like were they
just not allowed to say Siegfried and
Roy or did they just not know that that
was that guy probably weren't allowed to
say it I don't know I don't know why I
don't think I don't think that would be
well okay so the thing about that the
reason why this movie is called
witchboard
is because they were actually going to
call it Ouija which you know obviously
much later they did do a movie just
called Ouija
they were just going to call it that but
apparently
um is it Parker Brothers or whoever who
owns the they kind of were like and
actually the makers of which board I
guess like I said they're Indie
filmmakers they maybe they didn't know
any better but they shot like most of
the movie with the whole like Parker
Brothers Ouija board blah blah thing uh
without getting permission
uh to use that name maybe it didn't
occur to them that that was like a you
know a trademark so yeah so they
actually kind of got in trouble and they
ended up having to pay like I think
fifty thousand dollars or something like
that like to use it and they're like
yeah we would really rather you didn't
call the movie
Ouija so they had to call it witchboard
and I think at some point in the
original cut of the movie I think there
was a scene where Brandon the character
Brandon like says oh sometimes it's
called a witch board but I think they
took that out so I don't even think they
say the word in the movie I mean it's
just clearly a Ouija board like you'd
buy there's a couple different ones
here's one hand drawn ones yeah like the
one toward the end was actually cooler
because it was like kind of blue and it
looked like because he had to go to like
a um like a witchcraft store and buy one
one thing I didn't notice until I went
by some other heavy metal chick yeah
that's probably one of tawny's [__]
girlfriends probably I mean you know
um one thing I didn't notice until I was
watching like a couple breakdowns of
this movie I totally did not notice this
and I've seen this movie like a bunch of
times is that depending on what's going
on with the Ouija board because there's
lots of scenes of like Tawny it's her
character's name is Linda but I just
keep calling her Tony
um where she's using it like talking to
David who is supposedly a 10 year old
boy except most of the time it's like an
evil spirit and she doesn't know that
but so she's using it now if good [__]
is happening like she's actually talking
to the 10 year old boy then there's like
a little angel at the top of the Ouija
board and it looks like a little cherub
or something like that but if
um she's talking to like the evil spirit
then the angel is still there but it has
little demon wings like little bat wings
and is making like a little frowny face
I didn't notice that I didn't either but
then it's like I saw like somebody
showed like clips of it I was like holy
[__] that was a nice like little detail
I never did notice that and they said
yeah probably most people didn't notice
it I'm like you're right I did not
notice that yeah
um somebody said earlier that uh Howard
Stern cheated with uh Tawny Kitaen
that's why he got divorced okay do you
know that during go ahead during the
filming of this movie Tawny was also
having an affair with um O.J Simpson oh
okay I didn't know that he was married
at the time she obviously she was cute
uh I would say
she was kind of like
what
what was real popular in the 80s which
tended to be
kind of tall and skinny and those girls
look good in clothes
um she does take her clothes off she's
pretty stacked for a tall girl
uh I'd give her like an an 80s nine
she'd had a 10. she'd have been in 80s
10 if she had two big old fake titties
if they were like beach balls [__]
that's that was like the [__]
ultimate [__] look in the 80s
uh for the heavy metal guys the heavy
metal guys love that [__] I feel like in
like uh what was her name some of the
porn star girls were like that just
skinny with big fake [__] implants
um
that was just a style man
turn around the back they're flat as
hell
Ben says uh Ouija isn't a real word it
is a composite of we yes yes
well and actually they say that exact
thing in this movie so here's the thing
so all of these movies like use what I
always thought was the correct
pronunciation which is Ouija I have no
idea why people started calling a Ouija
board I'm like that's an a at the end
that's not how we say a answer to say I
guess easier to say It's like because it
Rhymes yeah but yeah so but there is a
scene very near the beginning of this
where Brandon says that exact thing he's
like we Jah you know that's how you're
like I said he's like super douchey
about it just we yeah [__] French
and then yeah we uh yeah so it should be
we uh technically yeah so we're all
pronouncing it right Parker Brothers man
Parker Brothers trying to make make a
butt yeah they just made that word up
yeah but like I said I don't know
because it the Parker Brothers one has
been around a while right I feel like
years yeah at least yeah
so did they like have a thing where they
told people how to pronounce it did they
get Ouija no I was like where do they
get Ouija it doesn't even look like that
I don't know it's just it doesn't matter
that's just how it really doesn't yeah
but um but yeah so this movie
I kind of feel like what okay so one
thing I wish they had done I kind of
wish I didn't mind the actor that played
the cop but I kind of wish they had
toned down that hole every time it's
like oh magic trick kind of so we made
an elephant disappear like every single
time he shows up because he's trying to
like hint to Jim it's like hey I think
you're murdering people even though it's
a ghost spoiler alert
um but every time he just kind of like
uses this
magic kind of simile and it's just it
gets like really old yeah so there's
that
um and I do
is doesn't this doesn't have like a lot
of Gore in it it doesn't have like a lot
of special effects because like I said
they didn't have a ton of money
um but I do I wish they had done more
with the evil spirit the guy who's
actually like haunting the board because
this is it's not a demon it's a guy who
when he was alive was like an Ax
Murderer or something and he ended up
like living in that same house that they
lived in
and that guy that played him I don't
even think he was an actor I think he
was just like a photographer he just
like was on the crew or something and
they're like hey you look evil come here
and like be in this movie and like I
think he was in another movie called
witch trap as well which is kind of like
this one but it's I wish they had done
more with him because he was so cool
looking like he really looked like an
evil [__] he almost had like an Angus
scrim type thing going on you know what
I mean so I kind of feel like I wish
they had done more with that because the
whole premise of this much like a lot of
um haunting episodes yeah was that
well I think at some points they were
contacting the 10 year old boy because
they did find out that that was a real
kid that had died and I think some every
now and then they were talking to that
kid but most of the time I think every
time that Tawny was using the board
because she used it by herself which
you're not supposed to do then it was
the evil guy pretending to be that kid
right so that's so that was kind of like
the whole premise but I kind of wish
they had done more with that guy because
you really don't see him you see him
once in like a dream sequence where he's
like in the hospital where Tony went
because she like hit her head or
something and like he come and like cuts
her head off you know what I mean but
it's just a dream and then like you see
him again like at the end but that's
about it like you only see him like a
couple seconds and that guy had such a
cool look and I kind of wish they had
done more with that
Styx is asking what a 90s what a 90s 10
was okay and 90s 10 was shorter curvier
blonde hair with the parted on the side
with a tongue ring
a [__] belly shirt with a [__]
belly ring and jankos never and
remember those girls the raver girls
what the [__] jankos that that was
like a 90s stand
[__] Jenkins remember those well yeah
he's [__] each [__] pant leg was
just was like
was like a waste of jeans they're
ridiculous like they're walking around
in two skirts a skirt on each leg yes
whenever you saw those girls they were
just sitting down all the time smoking
cigarettes then they'd get up walking it
was like it was like a tent walking away
it was a trip man I like that [__]
though it was cute I got 90s well I mean
if you were like a tiny skinny girl it
was cute
well it was just cute man I remember
them
I'm just saying you guys you got a lot
of drag like walking in those you know
what I mean unless you it's like slowing
you down because it was so much it was
so much fabric I'm gonna see if I can
find what I'm talking about I'll show
you go ahead
uh but yeah so I this wasn't I don't
think this this can't have been the
first movie that had like that was
solely focused on a Ouija board I was
trying to I know there were some like
prior to this but you know obviously The
Exorcist had that [__] too because you
know she was talking to Captain howdy on
the Ouija board yeah
um I kind of feel like the Exorcist went
into I don't know if they actually used
the phrase that they use in this movie
which is Progressive entrapment you know
what I mean where like where the ghost
like starts being handy and like you
know being friendly and like doing [__]
for you like in this particular movie
it's like oh hey you're that wedding
ring or the Eng I found it go ahead
good yeah never mind oh I distracted her
Cisco look she's sitting down and
everything
sitting down and everything can't see it
but that was that was nice okay go ahead
I forgot what I was talking about
I guess it wasn't important well if you
can't remember it then it was well yeah
well I couldn't get whatever you can't I
don't even know what you're talking
about yeah I know because you're not
listening you're too busy looking for
random pictures random picture so I'm
just trying okay
no I was saying what it was was that
yeah like the first thing when she first
started using it like it was being
helpful like it was telling her like
this ring that you lost it's like in the
sink drain and she pulls it out she's
like oh my God it's really in there and
it's like so you know it so it was
helping her out and it was trying to
like get her to like use the board more
it was like pretending to be this little
kid and then like she started acting
weird but then like she started swearing
a lot and being like really cranky and
[__] like that but then she also thought
she was pregnant and then Jim thought
she was pregnant so they thought that's
why she was acting like that not like
she was possessed or nothing so it was
that kind of thing now here's another
thing
that I kind of thought that they were
gonna do and then they didn't do
because
for a while in the movie
she thinks that she's pregnant
and because there's like at the
beginning there's this whole
um setup where they talk about
reincarnation because they're talking to
this kid you know through the board like
the ghost David whatever they're talking
to him and he's saying oh well you can
come back but you can like choose your
parents so I thought her being pregnant
I thought that was going to lead to like
the the demon or the ghost or something
like that wanting to like come back in
her baby you know what I mean I kind of
thought that's what they were leading up
to but then it turns out that she's
actually not pregnant yeah I think the
reason that they had her be pregnant was
so there would be like some plausible
deniability like why she was acting
weird like why nobody would immediately
be alarmed that she was acting
differently because they're like oh well
she's pregnant and everybody knows
pregnant [__] because it was just it
was just bad writing so it was something
like that but well it I don't even know
so much that it just seemed like a
missed opportunity because I thought
that's what they were setting up I was
like I thought that's what that whole
reincarnation discussion at the
beginning it probably was going to go
that way but maybe then they could
didn't have the money to shoot certain
scenes so they changed it it was
probably all it was because I remember
when that happened I was like oh they're
not going that way okay
but uh no I thought that it was gonna
come it was gonna pop out of her baby
yeah see so you weren't so I wasn't the
only one that's not that because yeah
because I thought that's why they were
pretty shut up I'm pretty sure it was
going to maybe but then they they
couldn't afford to do that because I
think the original
um version of this script was much
longer it was almost like yeah like at
like twice as long another idea happens
and then they don't go that way I
immediately go Oh okay they couldn't
afford to do that that's that maybe yes
maybe that's what it was but it's just
yeah because it did definitely seem like
they were
trying to set that up very very
deliberately guaranteed they were going
to try to do that yeah because what
would have been the point then of like
the whole discussion with David the
ghost like oh yeah I can pick my I
already shot that material and they were
gonna throw it away so they had to
change the story yeah the Italians did
the same thing all the time in Seattle
well you know that's that's true okay
well kind of basically they just shot
well although well I mean a lot of those
were actually based on books so like you
know like Edgar allos books and stuff
like that like I thought I could have
sworn us we saw some programs where they
just they shot some [__] and they didn't
know how the movie was going to end they
just kept shooting and they go well I
don't even think that's I mean that's
not just um giala movies that's like a
lot of movies like especially like
independent movies you know what I mean
they're just kind of like I don't know
they're just kind of like well let's
just like see where it goes you know
what I mean but uh yeah so they shot
part of this in Big Bear
um up the the lake and everything like
that that's kind of where they did the
one thing and then some of it was in the
Higgins verbeck Hirsch Mansion which I'm
pretty sure
I think wasn't waxworks shot there as
well I know there was like a couple
other horror movies shot at that same
house here's another thing that was kind
of and I'm I guess I wasn't the only
person confused about this because I was
watching another review and they said
they were confused about this too at
first because the first scene is
basically like the party like where
Brandon comes there and he brings the
Ouija board and blah blah and then like
they're outside in the driveway and I'm
sitting there going wait this is Tony
and Jim's house because Tony does not
appear to have a job and Jim just works
on a construction site I'm like that's a
[__] Mansion they live in holy [__]
how can they like afford that but it
took me a while because it just looked
like a regular house but it took me a
while to realize that this house was
like a mansion but had been converted
into Apartments because it was like
probably half an hour to the movie
before I'm like oh they live in an
apartment inside this Mansion because
it's been converted because they talked
about the landlady and stuff like that
and the landlady was actually
um Rose Marie who was on that old man
what the hell was that old show that she
was on she wasn't in this very much
either but she was maybe in only a
couple of scenes which was kind of a
shame because she's kind of cute but she
like played their land landlord but yeah
I mean overall though I
did for some reason this movie always
kind of like really stuck with me from
the 80s and that's why I wanted to like
re-watch it because I was kind of
curious to see if it held up because I
saw it so many times back then and I
think it still does but I can see why it
has mixed reviews too because if you're
expecting like ooh balls to the wall
like 80s horror with all this Gore and
stuff like that it's not like that and
it's not even
um there's not even really a lot of
nudity in it like Tawny contains naked
in it but it's not you can barely see it
you know I mean because the way it's
shot you can kind of see it but it's not
like really but you know what it wasn't
gratuitous right you know what's
interesting too is I feel like
um a lot of the shots in this this has
some like pretty creative
shock compositions and like the one shot
I think a lot of people make fun of it
where Jim like falls out a window at the
end and it looks like and it's kind of
like really bad green screen and stuff
but I thought I'm like yeah it looks
crazy like it looks weird but I thought
he was homaging Psycho like that you
know where he falls down the stairs at
the end where it's like Oh I thought
because that's what it looked like to me
because there's some other shots in here
that are very hitchcocky and I think it
was just bad special effects
well I don't know about that though
because like I said some of the other
shots deliberately looked hitchcocky in
and the guy was a film student so he
would have known about Hitchcock's film
techniques I would presume so it does
really seem like a lot of the shots in
there were deliberately modeled after
Hitchcock shots and I think like I was
even reading an older view of this from
the time like back in the 80s it said
this is like a Hitchcock movie
so I can't be the only one that thinks
that but I'm pretty sure that that lasts
yeah it doesn't look great and
especially it doesn't look great if you
don't think that it's an homage to
Psycho but I think it might be because
it looks almost exactly like that angle
in that shot and everything like that
um all right so you seem like you're
getting all crabby and [__] over there
because you're going
no you're doing like that [__] over
there all right so yeah no kidding um so
uh
so tomorrow uh we gotta do haunting a
haunting month she's the end of the show
she's putting it on me okay well you
know no you're you're not talking about
sex asked me what Zach asked what what a
2010 was
that have been something like Avril
Lavigne with tight shirt a tight short
shirt good hair and those white belts
remember the jeans or the white belts
yeah yeah something like that yeah
um so does anybody have any
recommendations on what haunting episode
they'd like us if you don't we'll just
like pick one out of
out of a hat or something yeah
um Summer Wind video version
they want us to redo some of it summer
wind I mean we've done a couple shows
about Summer Wind I mean if you one of
our [__] top shows people love summer
with I mean if you really want us to but
I could do Summer Wind again we could do
Summer Wind or somebody asked us um to
do what was the what was the one that
took that was in uh was it where was in
Thailand hungry ghosts or something I
think somebody asked us to redo that one
yeah Hungry Ghost was a good one that's
one of the better that was one of the
better episodes
I mean if you want to revisit Summerwind
again we can do I mean that's your
favorite episode it was one of the first
videos we ever did on this show yeah and
the audio it probably sucks by today's
standards that's true you should go back
and go look at that
and see what we talked about see what
we've missed
I mean I wouldn't mind doing that we
could do it again that's a good episode
or we could do hungry ghosts
we could put them both on well I mean
not in one episode I was gonna say yeah
let's not do that because I gotta I
gotta go out of town for a job interview
tomorrow I don't have a lot of time to
like be doing research all this [__]
like we could do summer win yeah I mean
we gotta watch it tonight and then I
gotta take notes while we're watching
and we gotta go back and uh refer to the
guy who owns Summerwind who remember who
no it wasn't summer one who was yeah he
didn't own it he was just part of the uh
restoration he was just like yeah yeah
he was like he was just on the show yeah
that was a long time ago yeah
but that's the thing if we do another
show about Summer Wind he might like
call me up and be like hey I want to be
on there
so it could be that like I don't know
how that's gonna work out and like I
said it's dude it's really hard for like
logistically it's hard for me to like
get guests on the show anymore because
it's just kind of like everything's a
pain and I don't really know how it's
gonna work out you know so uh so yeah so
I don't really want to open that can of
worms but uh but yeah so I don't know
we'll think about it and
um I'll announce it sometime tomorrow
like I said I tomorrow I gotta go out of
town in the morning and then I'll be
back way before the show but I won't
have as much time to do research as I
normally would but we will still be here
at six o'clock doing a haunting show so
hopefully you guys will be able to join
us and thank you for joining us today
talking about which board uh it's
actually on 2B if you would like to
watch it for free I don't know if the
other two are on there and I don't even
remember if they're any good so don't
come at me if they're not
um but yeah so we will see you guys
again tomorrow evening
good night